الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وافقت
اداره الغذاء والدواء على اول اللقاح
لفيروس الجهاز التنفسي المخلوي للاستخدام
في الولايات المتحده تمت الموافقه على
دواء المسمى
للاستخدام من قبل الاشخاص الذين يبلغون من
العمر 60 عاما او اكثر للوقايه من هذا
الفيروس الخطير كبار السن والاطفال يعدون
اكثر المعرضين للاصابه بهذا الفيروس نظرا
لضعف جهاز المناعه لديهم اما الخبراء
اعاده الفيؤكدون ان الموافقه على هذا
اللقاح تعد انجازا مهما للصحه العامه
للوقايه من مرض يمكن ان يهدد الحياه
العامه في الولايات المتحده على كل حال
المزيد من التفاصيل حول هذا الفيروس
واللقاح الجديد مع زميله لميس
يعد فيروس الجهاز التنفسي المخلوي احد
اشهر الفيروسات التي تصيب الجهاز التنفسي
مسببا التهاب الرئتين والمجرى التنفسي
الاصابه به شائعه لدى الاطفال دون العامين
وكبار السن فوق الستين عاما ويمكن ان يصيب
البالغين من الشباب ايضا تزيد خطوره
الفيروس لدى الاشخاص المصابين بامراض
مزمنه او ضعف الجهاز المناعي كبار السن
والاطفال اللقاح الامريكي الجديد وبحسب
اختبارات سريريه قلل بشكل كبير من خطر
الاصابه بامراض مرتبطه بفيروس الجهاز
التنفسي المخلاوي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات